now our next guest is how to Stella
career first in rugby league it leads
rhinos before moving into coaching
England's Rugby Union side along the way
he's made a name for himself fundraising
for motor neuron disease to raise
awareness of an illness his best friend
to perform a teammate Rob Burroughs is
suffering from with us now of course
um Kevin Simpsonville Kevin hi it's
great to see you we all of course
remember let's just start with those
images of you completing the Leeds
Marathon uh unbelievable tell me about
how you were feeling at the end
uh tired yeah
um but um just we've been able to do
some challenges to fundraise over the
last couple of years unfortunately Rob
hasn't been able to take part so to be
able to do something together
for him to be part of his a marathon in
his name in Leeds
for us to share in a really special
moment at the end for us to share in
just over four hours in each other's
company
um was fantastic and it was a really
special day 12 and a half thousand
people running Rob's name
six and a half thousand were competing
in their first ever Marathon all
inspired by a Rob
what made you pick him up at the end uh
we agreed that we'd have a special
finish
and um it was a really special moment
for both of us the marathon was built on
friendship and love and looking after
your teammate and looking after your
friend and
um yeah it was a really special moment
for both of us for those who don't know
um and who haven't followed this journey
um it's been
a real challenging one for Rob and for
everyone involved in the m d Community
um you know it's been tough to watch and
tough to be a part of but he is a the
best and biggest Warrior I've ever met
you've done a lot for motor neurone
disease to raise uh not just awareness
but a lot of funds as well since tell us
a little bit about what you've been
doing
yeah I think um
when a friend gets diagnosed with a
disease like this you want to try and
help you want to try and do your little
bit and made a promise to him that by
Christmas 2020 it was it was diagnosed
in December 2019 but by Christmas 2020
we'd have some money set aside so his
family was Secure for the rest of their
lives and Rob was diagnosed at 37 he had
three kids under 10.
unfortunately during 2020 as we all know
we got hit by Corbin and locked down and
that meant
um I didn't anticipate I would need to
run but I set out then to with a team to
try and run and raise some money and
we didn't expect what happened we were
completely overwhelmed but it meant we
raised a lot more than we expected and
we were able to use that to help them
indeed community and I think what comes
on the back of that is
um you start to give a community that's
been ravaged and devastated for decades
and some hope and that led to further
challenges which I've loved being a part
of and
rights enabled our team to do is have
interactions with the mnd community and
build some really strong connections
um and that's been a pleasure because
these these families are the best of us
and they've been challenged in the most
horrific where yet have a spirit and a
fight about on that
um
is really really special
friendship has progression developed uh
well we've been friends for a long time
I first met Rob when I was 14 and he was
12 and we'd both agreed professional
contracts
um at the ladranos in rugby league
um then when we both got into the first
team we've sat alongside each other for
15 years in the dressing room
and we're shared in some incredible
moments as part of
um a team that won a lot trophies but
also went through a lot of adversity
together as as part of that team and I
think then you finish playing and and
players go on their own New Path
but when something like this happens
when you've gone through being part of
such a strong team and something tragic
like this happens you come together and
you try and help and and that's what our
group of try to do
um you have spoken previously about how
your relationship with Rob inspired your
career change to become a coach yes
definitely he's inspired me in so many
different ways so
um
I think when I go and see him I get a
great deal of perspective
and I get a real mix of emotions I'm
uplifted I'm inspired yet I'm really sad
at what this disease has done
and Rob certainly taught me I needed to
live my life and took some risk
and be prepared to be uncomfortable
because he's uncomfortable every single
day and as is this community and
actually I want to make the most of my
life and I felt that after the first
challenge
um I got a real sense of purpose and
fulfillment from trying to help people
and I thought the best way I can perhaps
use that in my role or in my next job
would be
excuse my experience as a rugby player
to try and help people on the field and
um yeah that's where I am now I'm sure
you touch on that in in the book don't
you tell us about the book yeah so I've
never wanted to write a book
and I don't particularly like running
and I found myself for the last three
and a half years
I've wrote a book in and then much of it
is about the running we've undertaken I
think over the last I don't know five or
six years we've run 37 38 marathons now
um and many of them for Robin for the m
d community so
um I didn't want to write a typical
Sports person's book you know a typical
autobiography it needed to be different
and I was conscious when I retired from
playing rugby that rugby wouldn't Define
the rest of my life it was 35 and didn't
quite know what path was going to go
down next but
um Rob has certainly inspired me to go
in a different direction and
I think because of that
um
you know that's why I agreed to do the
book and I say agreed it was Rob's idea
Rob wrote his own and then 18 months ago
I said came you need to do a book
um and that's what it started okay so
your coach Rugby Union but you played
rugby league how does he feel about you
changing code uh the beautiful thing
about Rob is he wants the best for me
and he'd support me no matter where or
what I did
um he understands
um that how important coaching is he was
a coach himself and actually took on
took some risk being comfortable try
something new
um he's 100 behind what I would say is
working in Rugby Union working with uh I
was originally with Leicester tigers and
now I'm with England
the players The Spectator his responses
the coaches I work with are unbelievable
people and I feel very very fortunate
which code do you prefer
that's a play I believe it's coach for
the right answer how much money have you
raised
um well the team and I'm going to say
the team I think we are over 8 million
pounds now amazing work well thank you
very much amazing thanks very much and
the book's called the extra mile amazing
it's good to see you thank you